les sciences avec la fabrication du plus
grand télescope spatial jamais réalisé
il possède un miroir géant de trois
mètres cinquante de diamètre et il est
conçu en france à toulouse l'engin sera
lancée en 2007 et permettra si tout va
bien de scruter la formation des
premières étoiles
patrice pelé mathias secondes sur place
dans son berceau comme abb
c'est une pièce magnifique unique en son
genre avec trois mètres cinquante de
diamètre voici le plus grand miroir
spatiale du monde coefficient de
réflexion 98%
il sera placé ici à l'avant du futur
télescope infrarouge qui portera le nom
d'air shell 10 heures de réflexion
quatre années de fabrication est plutôt
que le verre trop lourd
c'est finalement en carbure de silicium
en céramique qu'il a été conçu il aurait
dû donc peser une tonne 5
il ne fait que 300 kg la fabrication en
un seul morceau de ce miroir est
impossible il a fallu procéder à la
réalisation de 12 pétales qui ont été
assemblés par broyage les uns avec les
autres et ensuite la surface obtenu a
été rectifiée et polie pour obtenir ce
miroir le miroir de l'agencé spatiale
européenne fouillera les endroits
obscurs de l'espace à l'intérieur
desquels pour le moment on ne voit rien
mais grâce au rayonnement infrarouge
récupéré par le télescope au devraient
revisiter l'univers herschel va
permettre aux scientifiques de
comprendre mieux la formation des
étoiles et la formation des galaxies à
partir des toiles qui est un processus
qui a démarré depuis 12 milliards
d'années mais qui depuis est en
permanente évolution évidemment le
lancement du télescope herschel est
programmé pour 2007 par mois 200 degrés
il devrait fonctionner quatre ans
ensuite le beau miroir
ira se perdre dans l'espace